>> Good morning or good evening or whatever.
My name is Paolo DallOglio and I am a monk
in the desert of Syria and I speak very, very
bad English although I wish to speak Arabic.
The next video will be in Arabic. Yes the
role models are important for our region and
for our society and those models, let me say
models should be from the ethical point of
view, from the moral point of view, something
really not only outstanding, at the level,
should be convincing, coherent and this will
be luck. We like as a society, we look to
appreciate transparency. We are built into
looking and seeking the relationship with
power. The power of the Father, the power
of the professor, the power of the employer.
We all over the world, but here power comes
before upper and after the law and justice
and so role model means for me deeply to look
for transparency and for people that are able
to pay, I would not say pay with the blood,
pay with the passions, paying with a consistency,
paying with a gracefulness of the kind of
values that they want to embody in the life
and the society. We have models in our religious
models, ideals, people have been able to put
spiritual values before [inaudible] and after
interests and this is what is saving our society
until today. Family values, religious values
so that we have something to build on but
we have not only to stay attached to it, it's
not enough. We have to start new life on that
base with a lot of capacity on invention [inaudible]
and capacity of change. Transparency and coherence.